[Musique]
chers militants comme je m'y étais
engagé c'est à vous qu'il revient de
modifier nos statuts pour définir la
méthode de désignation de notre candidat
à l'élection présidentielle
ça se fera par un vote électronique le
vote va s'ouvrir le vendredi 24 à 18
heures c'est à dire demain jusqu'à
samedi 18h deux versions s'offre à vous
pour voter soit vous choisissez la
version 1 la version 1 c'est une
procédure ouverte à l'ensemble des
sympathisants de la droite et du centre
où vous faites le choix de la version 2
la version 2 7 la désignation se fera
pas tout seul c'est à dire uniquement
les adhérents les républicains dans les
deux cas la désignation se fera le 4
décembre
c'est à dire la même période pour les
campagnes présidentielles précédentes
que ce soit lorsque l'on a désigné
jacques chirac nicolas sarkozy ou
françois fillon
c'était fin novembre là ce sera le 4
décembre nous rappelle bien la procédure
samedi nous choisissons la méthode de
désignation
donc soit un système ouvert à l'ensemble
des sympathisants qui se reconnaissent
dans les valeurs de la droite et du
centre soir un congrès réservée aux
seuls militants c'est donc le choix de
la méthode de désignation et le 4
décembre ce sera le choix du candidat
nous ferons à ce moment là d'ici là bien
chaque candidat aura le temps de faire
sa campagne
[Musique]